ethan is with us in seattle hey Ethan
welcome to the Dave Ramsey show thanks
for taking my call
sure what's up so I'm the type of person
who isn't a morning person and tends to
sleep into the last minute before I had
to work mm-hm
I'm trying to change that better myself
or my family or my future and I was
hoping you might have some tips on how
to become a morning person and make my
mornings productive mmm how old are you
27 so what you do for a living I'm a
local delivery driver I sell my truck
you know for all the minion freelance
okay good all right
yeah good to be alert if you're gonna be
at the helm of a big rig huh yeah well I
mean I just have a tendency it's where I
sleep in and leave the house before my
family gets up and then only have about
an hour at home to spend at the family
so instead of doing stuff after I get
home from work I want to be able to get
some stuff done and you know be
productive in the mornings before I
leave to work and having a hard time and
struggling with that I'm not sure what
is it you're wanting to do in the
mornings that you're not doing maybe
light reading in maybe it worked out
here and there and pretty much just
gonna early jump to my day to be honest
okay cool well I have a friend of mine
that's uh in his 70s and when I was so
he's 20-something years older than me
obviously and I actually worked for him
for a short period of time and he is one
of the most renowned scholars I have
ever met on the book of Proverbs and for
many years he got up at four o'clock in
the morning he may still for all I know
and study he was really really intense
about studying the book of Proverbs and
studying the Bible and you know
understanding Hebrew the Greek and so
forth and all the different things and
just that was his goal he was very very
intense about it envis it was quite
amazing the his knowledge of it and so I
was kind of asking him the same question
I'm like I get up at 4 o'clock and the
more
and do that I mean it's kind of like wow
you know what I'm saying right yeah
you know what he told me I go to bed
early you know and so I am I mean that
my motor runs beautifully still to this
day at midnight now this I'm getting
older and so I'm tired at midnight but
I'm a night person too and sometimes
you're just the way your body works your
brain works or whatever your spirit
some people are night people some people
are morning people but I get up at
either for 45 or 55 15 almost every
morning somewhere around there and I
have for probably 20 years 25 years and
all I did was that's a after talking to
that one guy I just said kind of like
you I thought there's some stuff I want
to get done in the morning I got to get
started earlier and the only way to do
it is I do need a house to sleep I
really do and so I just go to bed
earlier because it's just worth it to me
and so yeah I'm kind of old man you know
my grandpa one he always got up before
o'clock in the morning he was a country
guy and he went to work at 6 a.m. and he
would get up 4:30 or something like that
and so you know if it was an 8:30 9:00
o'clock and there were still people at
the house he would stand up and say
honey we're going to go to bed so these
people can go home and he would get up
and leave and go to bed and the rest of
us would be sitting there for another
hour and so I haven't done that yet I
hadn't quite got that old man yet but I
may at some point I'm ok with going to
bed and you know it's really not I don't
have anything anymore insightful for you
than that but it helped me and that's
how I I'm still a night person but I get
a lot of productivity out of my mornings
now a lot of it the thing that you're
looking for there and a chance to work
out a chance to read the scriptures a
chance to spend time with Sharon I do
some writing in the morning some of
these blogs I've been putting out in the
last year I've been writing those in the
morning my mind's fresh on that kind of
thing I think I'm a little nicer in the
mornings
so so I'm really not on Twitter in the
morning I wait till I'm mad later in the
day to get on Twitter yes you know you
just kind of learn that stuff and get in
a rhythm with it and that's what you're
looking for but you do have to you know
you have to have the time to do the
other stuff